[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin schönen guten Abend katja
ist bei mir von dir gibt es später
Fußball plus X und Y und Z viele tolle
themensport bis gleich da sind die
Themen an diesem Freitag
mit Zuwanderern gegen den
Fachkräftemangel der Bundestag
beschließt das neue Einwanderungsrecht
schwere Unwetter viele Schäden tief
Lampe wütet über Deutschland aber es
geht glimpflicher aus als befürchtet
und Hitzestress für werdende Mütter eine
Studie belegt bei hohen Temperaturen
steigt das Risiko für Frühgeburten
deutlich
[Musik]
Mogelpackung schimpft die Union die
Innenministerin spricht vom modernsten
Einwanderungsrecht der Welt gemeint ist
das Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz dass
der Bundestag heute mit
Regierungsmehrheit beschlossen nach
Wochen des ampelzoffs lief es zumindest
beim Thema Zuwanderung ziemlich
geräuschlos schauen wir uns die Pläne
jetzt mal an
Fachkräfte aus Ländern außerhalb der EU
können über ein Punktesystem nach
Deutschland kommen wer genügend Punkte
hat dabei zählen etwa Abschlüsse oder
Deutschkenntnisse darf hierzulande ein
Jahr lang Arbeit suchen für Asylbewerber
die schon in Deutschland sind gilt mit
Job oder Ausbildung können Sie eine
Aufenthaltserlaubnis als Fachkraft
beantragen und für alle anerkannten
Fachkräfte soll der Familiennachzug
ausgeweitet werden auch auf Eltern und
Schwiegereltern Bernd Team
guten Morgen
Händeringen suchte das katholische
Klinikum Bochum nach Pflegekräften und
fand Aniko you aus Kamerun seit einem
Jahr und nach einigem bürokratischen
Aufwand arbeitet die 28-Jährige hier ein
Glücksfall für beide Seiten
nette Kollege unterschiedliche Kultur
hätten wir die ausländischen
Pflegekräfte nicht hätten wir
tatsächlich umgesetzte Stellen laut
Experten braucht Deutschland 400.000
zugewanderte Fachkräfte pro Jahr die
Regierung reformiert jetzt das
entsprechende Gesetz der man Fachkräften
gilt als eine der größten
Wachstumsbremsen für die Wirtschaft in
Deutschland und deshalb ist dieser
Gesetzentwurf ein Riesenschritt für die
Zukunft mit der chancenkarte nach
kanadischem Vorbild soll es Punkte geben
für zum Beispiel Qualifikation
Sprachkenntnisse Berufserfahrung Alter
oder Deutschlandbezug wer genügend
dieser Punkte vorweist darf in
Deutschland ein Jahr lang einen Job
suchen wenn der Lebensunterhalt
gesichert ist
Jobangebot und ausreichende
Qualifikation profitieren neu ist auch
der sogenannte Spurwechsel Asylsuchende
die vor dem 29 März 23 in einem
Asylverfahren waren können den Antrag
zurücknehmen und sich als
Arbeitssuchende bewerben was passiert
denn
wenn der
besonderer doch nicht zu qualifiziert
ist und sofort wieder auf die Straße
gesetzt wird und dann aber nicht
heimreißt haben Sie denn schon die
Rückübernahmeabkommen mit allen Ländern
haben Sie denn schon die Garantie dass
die Heimreise die Regierungsparteien
verteidigen den Spurwechsel wer eine
Qualifikation habe können Sie jetzt auch
einbringen wir geben Menschen die
jahrzehntelang zum Abwarten und nichts
tun ver
[Applaus]
dammt langfristig in Deutschland
beschäftigt zu werden die Klinik in
Bochum hofft auf mehr Bewerbungen egal
woher hier brauchen Sie jede Hand die
arbeitet
holen wir Theo Koll dazu Theo turbulente
ampelwochen liegen ja hinter uns wie
wichtig ist der so ein fachkräftegesetz
das zumindest in den eigenen rein
ziemlich glatt durchgeht
also wenn die Ampel auch so eine neue
chancenkarte bekommen würde wie die sich
künftig bewerben und ausländischen
Fachkräfte dann hätte sie sich heute
wahrscheinlich selbst ein paar
Pluspunkte eingetragen sowohl für ein
eher geräuschloses Gesetzesprojekt als
auch was sehr viel wichtiger ist für die
teilweise Lösung eines massiven und seit
langem bestehenden problemens 400.000
Einwanderer braucht der deutsche
Arbeitsmarkt jedes Jahr wir haben es
eben gehört aber die in Rente gehen ein
Babyboomer plus Abwanderung reißen
riesige personelle Lücken das heutige
Gesetz soll zumindest mal 75
000 Menschen jährlich nach Deutschland
bringen es ist denn erster wichtiger
Schritt und dennoch ja nur ein Teil
dessen was noch nötig ist zusätzlich
helfen beim Arbeitskräftemangel dürfte
auch der ebenfalls beschlossene eben
angesprochene Spurwechsel also der
erlaubte Schritt aus dem Asylverfahren
in den Arbeitsmarkt es war einfach nie
sinnvoll so viele Menschen über Jahre
das Arbeiten zu verbieten danke für die
Einordnung nach Berlin Theo
gegen den Fachkräftemangel wurde heute
im Bundestag außerdem eine gesetzliche
Ausbildungsplatz Garantie beschlossen
die umfasst auch Art so wie es
Unterkunft und Fahrtkosten zu erstatten
sollte der Ausbildungsplatz weiter
entfernt sein außerdem beschlossen die
Parlamentarier heute Maßnahmen gegen
arzneifer Engpässe etwa viel genutzte
Medikamente verpflichten zu bevorraten
oder Preisregeln zu lockern
seit Wochen da geht es aufwärts für die
AFD und zwar in allen Umfragen in
Thüringen wo der Verfassungsschutz die
Partei als gesichert rechtsextremistisch
einstuft hat sie einen konstant hohen
Zuspruch bei den Landratswahlen vor
knapp zwei Wochen in Sonneberg war er so
hoch dass sein afd-kandidaten nur ganz
knapp scheiterte aber am Wochenende
könnte er die Stichwahl gewinnen und
somit Deutschlands erster AFD Landrat
werden Daniela Sonntag
für Robert Sesselmann wäre es ein Erfolg
der für seine Partei weit über den
Landkreis hinausreichen dürfte
46,7% vor zwei Wochen nah dran der erste
afd-landrat in Deutschland zu werden für
ein Interview stand der dem ZDF nicht
zur Verfügung auf seinen Wahlplakaten
vor allem bundesthemen auch Jürgen
Körper der Gegenkandidat von der CDU
sieht diese Landratswahl massiv von der
Bundespolitik überlagert die Stimmung
ist schon sehr angespannt was auch immer
gerade Richtung Berlin gerade in
Richtung große Politik was dieses ganze
Gebäude Energiegesetz angeht die
Geschichte das ist das was bei den
Menschen viele Wunden hinterlassen hat
die Ampel Diskussion treffen hier auf
eine Region die traditionell konservativ
geprägt ist und vom Mittelstand lebt die
Arbeitslosenquote ist niedrig aber auch
das Lohnniveau lockdowns Inflation
Energiepreise viele haben das sehr
deutlich im Portemonnaie gespürt die
Leute sind sehr unzufrieden und
mit der ganzen Politik überhaupt ich
wünsche mir dass die AFD nicht gewinnt
ich wünsche mir dass die AFD noch an
Kraft gewinnt nicht weil ich
rechtsradikal bin oder sonst irgendwas
aber es ist doch ein klares Zeichen
vielleicht auch mal nach Berlin ein
Signal so kann man die Stärke der AFD
vor allem aus der Schwäche der anderen
Parteien meinen Experten über keinerlei
taugliche regierungskonzepte und
trotzdem ist sie in der Lage sich
mittlerweile als fast
gesellschaftsfähige Kraft zu
präsentieren es gelingt also den
klassischen Parteien offensichtlich
nicht mehr die AFD an ihrer Lehre zu
stellen wer für die nächsten sechs Jahre
Sonneberger Landrat wird wird wohl auch
von der Wahlbeteiligung abhängen vor
zwei Wochen lag die bei nur rund 50%
. über unseren Köpfen hat zehn Tage lang
ein riesiges luftwaffenmanöver
stattgefunden das ist jetzt vorbei und
die Bundeswehr die das ganze koordiniert
hat sagt alles lief reibungslos geübt
wurde die Verlegung von
Luftstreitkräften 250 Flugzeuge waren
dabei aus NATO Ländern aber auch aus
anderen Staaten anders als befürchtet
gab es dadurch im zivilen Luftverkehr
nur wenige Verspätung
zum Krieg in der Ukraine da steht die
Stadt herson im Süden weiter unter dem
Beschuss der russischen Armee nach
Angaben der Behörden wurden dabei
mindestens drei Zivilisten getötet und
drei weitere verletzt allein heute seien
in der Regionalhauptstadt 26 Geschosse
eingeschlagen kämpft gleichzeitig mit
den Folgen der Staudamm Zerstörung vor
gut zwei Wochen als große Wassermassen
das Gebiet überfluteten
die ukrainische Führung sagt sie komme
mit ihrer gegen Offensive voran man
müsste aber klug und überlegt Vorgehen
das Leben der eigenen Soldaten habe
oberste Priorität so einen
präsidentenberater aber das menschliche
Leid durch putinskrieg ist natürlich
gewaltig Alisa jung hat mit verwundeten
Soldaten in einem Krankenhaus in Kiew
gesprochen
sie kämpfen bei der Offensive im Süden
um ihr Land hier im Norden in Kiew
weiter um ihr Leben ukrainische Soldaten
mit schwersten Verletzungen werden in
diesem Krankenhaus behandelt wenn die
Soldaten an der Frontlinie verwundet
werden findet dort die Erstversorgung
statt dann versucht man ihn in lokalen
Krankenhäusern zu helfen und wenn es
auch dort nicht weitergeht dann kommen
Sie hier hin in die Hauptstadt sie sehen
solche Verletzungen inzwischen täglich
Opfer von minenschrap Nells und Schüssen
in den letzten Wochen hat die Zahl und
die Schwere der Verletzungen zugenommen
berichten die Ärzte die Versorgung nahe
der Front wird schwieriger das größte
Problem war es wurde viel Zeit
verschwendet weil er in einem
Krankenhaus behandelt wurde wo er keine
entsprechende Wundversorgung und
Behandlung bekommen konnte
ob dieser Patient sein Bein behalten
wird
von Vadim führbardim dieses Bild hat ein
Kind aus dem Dorf gemalt für den
22-Jährigen Soldaten seit vier Monaten
ist er in diesem Krankenhaus verletzt in
bachmut im Kampf oh dann haben sie das
Artilleriefeuer gestartet und eine Mine
ist explodiert wir waren zu fünft die
Mine landete direkt in unserer Mitte
zwei Jungs sind gestorben und ich habe
irgendwie überlebt
aber beide Beine verloren er hofft auf
Prothesen will wieder laufen lernen ob
das geht und wann weiß war die nicht nur
eins er will sein Land weiter
unterstützen
die Folgen des Klimawandels bringen
besonders die armen Länder der Welt an
ihre finanziellen Grenzen wie die
Industriestaaten helfen können darüber
hat ein internationaler Gipfel in Paris
zwei Tage lang beraten im Mittelpunkt
standen Überlegungen des globale
Finanzierungssystem solidarischer zu
machen so könnte
ärmeren Ländern der Klimaschutz beim
Schuldenabbau angerechnet werden
Frankreichs Präsident macron war für
mehr Investitionen aus den
Industriestaaten verpflichten der
Beschlüsse gab es allerdings nicht
ja tiefschwarze Gewitterwolken jagten
gestern übers Land es gab
Unwetterwarnungen zu Haus Sturzregen und
Hagel mehrere Menschen wurden verletzt
alles in allem kams aber weniger schlimm
als befürchtet von eher geringen Schäden
sprechen heute die Versicherungen über
turbulente Stunden und das Aufräumen
danach Lena sünderbruch
tief Lambert hat einige Rekorde
gebrochen im Norden und Westen
Deutschlands brachte es teilweise nie
gesehene Regenmassen mit sich dieser
Deich in Dinslaken ist derartig
unterspült dass er zu brechen droht für
Anwohner bestehe keine Gefahr heißt es
die Feuerwehr arbeitet auf Hochtouren an
der Sicherung innerhalb von 24 Stunden
prasselten während des Unwetters teils
100 Liter pro Quadratmeter vom Himmel
auch besonders stark betroffen die
Region Kassel der Nahverkehr kam
vorübergehend zum Erliegen Schulen
blieben heute geschlossen auch wegen
Schäden durch Golfball große Hagelkörner
das war beängstigend wirklich es war
wirklich dunkel und es hat so laut
geknallt
dass ich gedacht habe im ganzen Haus
gehen die Fenster Schaden kaputt überall
in der Stadt wird aufgeräumt nur etwa 40
km entfernt berichten Anwohner von einem
Tornado zeigen zerstörte Dächer und
Terrassen an diesem Haus hat der Hagel
einschlaglöcher in der Wand hinterlassen
die Folgen der Gewitternacht führen in
Niedersachsen und Bremen noch immer zur
Einschränkungen im Zugverkehr an den
Flughäfen normalisiert sich die Lage in
Düsseldorf trafen das Unwetter und die
Folgen die Reisenden ausgerechnet zu
Beginn der Sommerferien
sind laute Worte gefallen Schlägerei auf
den Tresen weil sie hier wirklich
niemand zuständig wird und man wird nach
drei Stunden zum anderen Schalter
und zwei Stunden warte
im Ostharz hielten beinahe minütliche
Anrufe die Einsatzkräfte in Atem nicht
weit entfernt in Braunschweig zählt die
Feuerwehr seit gestern rund 4.500
Notrufe und mehr als 1000 Einsätze
also das ist eine Größenordnung die wir
als kommunale Feuerwehr alleine nicht
mehr schaffen deswegen haben wir auch in
der Nacht schon Unterstützung aus den
Nachbarlandkreisen geholt auch heute gab
es in einigen Regionen Deutschlands noch
einmal stark Regen tief Lambert zieht
nun aber weiter nach Polen
nach dem Regen soll es am Wochenende
wieder heiß werden besonders anstrengend
und gefährlich ist das für Schwangere
und Babys denn in hitzephasen gibt es
deutlich mehr Frühgeburten ab der 34
schwangerschaftswoche das zeigt eine
Studie der Uniklinik Hamburg steigen die
Temperaturen mehrere Tage hintereinander
auf 30 Grad dann erhöht sich das Risiko
um 20% bei mehr als 35 Grad sogar um 45
% Sven Ricken war auf einer
Frühchenstation
Daria wog 800 Gramm bei ihrer Geburt und
das war vor drei Wochen inzwischen ist
die über den Berg und wie sieht mehr als
1000 Gramm für Mutter Ramona obst hat
sich seit der frühen Geburt ihrer
Tochter viel geändert
denke ich positiv natürlich auch
weiterhin gute Entwickler keine
Komplikation also denke ich dass sie
sich auch in Zukunft weiter normal
entwickeln wird die Forschenden am
Hamburger Uniklinikum Griechen erstmals
20 Jahre Daten zu Frühgeburten mit
Wetterkarten ab das Ergebnis ist
eindeutig hoher temperaturstress ab 30
Grad wirkt sich direkt auf werdende
Mütter aus die Gefahr einer Frühgeburt
ab der 34 schwangerschaftswoche
verdoppelt sich Nein zu was wäre
identifizieren konnten war das
Temperaturen ab 30 Grad kritisch werden
und dann kommt auch hinzu wie lange
diese hitzeperie oder angedauert hat ein
bis zwei Tage sind auch gut verkraft zu
verkaufen aber drei Tage und mehr
erhöhen dann das Risiko für Frühgeburten
es ist möglich dass sich der menschliche
Körper an die Hitze anpasst aber das
wird so die Schätzung 20 bis 30 Jahre
dauern heute hilft für Schwangere nur
Sonne meiden bewegt sich im Zweifelsfall
würde das jetzt zum Beispiel das dass
man zum Beispiel von dietrichsen ein ja
eine Klimaanlage an ihrem Arbeitsplatz
zur Verfügung stellt oder gerade in
Hitzetagen vielleicht eine andere
Möglichkeit der körperlichen Schonung
Erholung die Studie belegt einen
direkten Einfluss der Klimaerwärmung auf
das ungeborene Kind stimmen die
Klimaprognosen würde bereits in zehn
Jahren jedes sechste Kind zu früh auf
die Welt kommen doppelt so viele wie
heute
Heizungsbauer Viessmann darf sein
wärmepumpengeschäft in die USA verkaufen
das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat
grünes Licht für den Deal gegeben
bedingung sei aber dass die wichtigsten
Standorte des Unternehmens für
mindestens fünf Jahre erhalten bleiben
der Hauptsitz im hessischen Allendorf
soll mindestens zehn weitere Jahre
bestehen Viessmann hatte den Verkauf
schon im April angekündigt der Preis
soll bei etwa 12 Milliarden Euro liegen
tagelang wurde im Nordatlantik nach dem
kleinen U-Boot Titan gesucht an Bord
drei Touristen ein Titanic Experte und
der Chef der Betreiberfirma des Bootes
und jetzt ist klar alle fünf sind tot
Teile des Wracks wurden am Meeresboden
gefunden das Mini U-Boot wurde auf dem
Weg zur Titanic durch den enormen
Wasserdruck im Bruchteil einer Sekunde
zerdrückt die US-Marine hatte wohl schon
am Sonntag einen entsprechendes Geräusch
registriert was bei dem Unglück konkret
passiert ist und welche Kritik es am
Betreiber gibt in unserer App finden sie
weitere Analysen
so jetzt zur U21 EM in Georgien und
Rumänien und da sorgt das Auftaktspiel
der deutschen Mannschaft für
mächtigschlag sein genau gegen Israel
zum einen war sportlich gegen Israel
noch sehr viel Luft nach oben eins zu
eins der Endstand zum anderen und vor
allem wegen der rassistischen
Beleidigung gegen kam und yusufu nachdem
beide jeweils einen Elfmeter verschossen
hatten
verärgerte Fans greifen schwarze
deutsche Nationalspieler im Netz an der
18-Jährige yussufer mukoko von Borussia
Dortmund ist getroffen und reagiert sagt
sowas ist ekelhaft und es tut einfach
nur weh Bundestrainer Antonio de salvo
findet klare Worte das ist ein Unding
ist eine eine Phase deswegen bin ich
auch auch ich persönliches schockiert
und enttäuscht viele Chancen zum
em-auftrag gegen Israel vergeben und
gleich zwei Elfmeter bereits in der
dritten Minute scheitert mukoko und in
der Schlussphase Jessica kam auch der
Führungstreffer gelingt im Außenseiter
durch dort torgemann mehr als den
Ausgleich schaffen die deutschen dann
nicht Jan Aurel bis sechs zum eins zu
eins entstand Frustration als Reaktion
der DFB antwortet und wir haben
beschlossen dass wir strafrechtlich
gegen diese Menschen vorgehen und wir
wollen einfach auch da ein Statement
setzen uns zu Wehr setzen alles andere
als ein optimaler Staat in diese U21 em
Tennisprofi alex steht im Halbfinale
morgen ab 14:10 Uhr auf dem Rasen in
Halle Westfalen und live im ZDF
Alexander es wäre gewann im
Viertelfinale überzeugen sieben zu fünf
und sechs zu drei gegen den Helene
Nicolas Yari und spielt nun gegen den
Kasachen Alexander bublik
sechster Tag der Special Olympics in
Berlin und einer der Publikumsmagneten
dieser Welt Spiele für Menschen mit
geistiger Beeinträchtigung sind die
Wettbewerbe im Gewichtheben
es ist auch die große Show des Film
Brown die die Zuschauer beim Gewicht
heben fasziniert der Kanadier 55 Jahre
alt sorgt für beste Stimmung in den
Berliner Messehallen zudem meistert das
61 Kilogramm leichte Multitalent
unglaubliche Gewichte stemmt 117,5 Kilo
und hebt ganze 175 kg Gold klar vor den
weitaus jüngeren Konkurrenten und die
Show des Film Brown geht weiter von
jetzt an im Publikum
[Applaus]
stark auf der letzten Etappe des Ocean
Race dem Bett segeln um die Welt gab es
für zwei Teams eine Begegnung der
besonderen und auch nicht ganz
ungefährlichen Art die Boote aus Holland
und Portugal wurden von Orcas
angegriffen sie Rampen das Boot Bissen
zum Teil in die Ruder es gab aber keine
Verletzten oder größere Schäden
bei der sicherer ist es da am Stadion in
Krakau da ist gerade Leichtathletik Team
em live zu sehen im ZDF sportstudio.de
danke Katja ja die Unwetter die sind
vorbei es gibt ein schönes
Sommerwochenende mehr dazu gleich von
Christa Orben um 22 Uhr Christian
Sievers mit dem heute journal und morgen
an dieser Stelle Barbara halbweg kommen
sie gut ins Wochenende und auf bald
[Musik]
ja guten Abend unser Unwetter tief
Lambert hier hat mit diesen
regengebieten die sich um sein Zentrum
hier einkreisen heute noch mal einiges
an Regen gebracht um die 50 Liter pro
Quadratmeter vor allem im Süden
Niedersachsen und in Sachsen-Anhalt
meist aber ungewittig das Ganze zieht
jetzt in der ersten Nachthälfte nach
Polen ab und die etwas kühlere und
stabilere Luft die der eingeflossen ist
hat man heute auch spürbar gemerkt es
war falls 10 Grad kühler als noch
gestern von Westen her da hat jetzt aber
auch die Wetterberuhigung schon
eingesetzt und zum Wochenende wird es
wieder heiß und so gibt es heute nach
den letzten Regen dann noch zwischen
Vorpommern und Ostbayern dahinter bildet
sich etwas Nebel der bisher noch der
bisher noch lebhafte Nordwestwind lässt
im nachtverlauf etwas nach die Werte
sinken auf 15 Grad an den Küsten
einstellig bleiben wir in höheren Lagen
wie zum Beispiel in Teilen der Oberpfalz
eine Nacht zum Durchlüften morgen wird
es dann von Westen wie gesagt schon
wieder heißer mit 29 bis 31 Grad
ansonsten haben wir angenehme
Temperaturen zwischen 22 und 27 Grad im
Land etwas dichtere Wolken im Norden
dann nieselt es kaum was viel Sonne nur
harmlose Quellwolken gibt es am Sonntag
wird es ein richtiger Sommertag mit
Temperaturen bis 34 Grad am Montag dann
unbeständiger mit einer Kaltfront
überqueren uns von West nach Ost wieder
Schauer und Gewitter tschüss